You know, it's so rare that I get a chance
to talk to someone else who does this job.
It is, and I loved it when you on my show
for the same reason.
Yes.
And I'd go and talk to the others, but they're assholes.
(audience laughs)
It's true.
It's really true.
I don't know.
It's true.
He's the only nice, no, I'm kidding.
Wait a minute, yeah, okay.
No.
But I did want to talk to you about the fact that
you've been doing something, I love to do,
you've been traveling.
You went to Russia.
Oh yeah, this past summer--
And that is a country I've always wanted to go there--
Never been?
Never been to Russia.
I'm fascinated.
How was that?
What was that experience like?
Uh, a little spooky.
We went there because there's so much talk
about Russians interfering with our elections
and our country and the possible connections
between the Trump campaign and, of course, the pee-pee tape,
you know, at the Moscow Ritz-Carlton, I think it was.
We used to have classier scandals.
We used to have, like, Teapot Dome and Watergate.
Now we have pee-pee tape.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
It's depressing.
You gotta give
the people what they want, Conan.
You gotta give them what they want.
You gotta give people what they want.
It's what the people want.
So no one had gone
over to see what the pee-pee tape room was
'cause it was a presidential suite at the Ritz-Carlton,
so I said, can't we rent it?
So we went over and we rented the pee-pee tape room.
The room where Trump allegedly--
Allegedly, it's all alleged, Conan.
It's all alleged.
And I went over there and I looked at it
and it's totally believable.
(audience laughs)
Totally.
This is forensic analysis.
I went in completely,
completely neutral--
Is there a drain in the middle of the floor?
What do you mean it's believable?
No, no, but I will tell you this,
one of the things they said is that the reason
that they might know is that because the KGB or the,
I forgot what it's called now, whatever the modern--
The GR--
The GRU
or something like that,
they've got cameras everywhere and I was staying
in the same hotel and they said, like,
"Just know that they're gonna see you all the time."
So I was naked constantly.
(audience laughs)
That was a real treat for them, I bet, huh?
Just buck ass, you know,
downward facing dogs all the time.
Sure.
Just drink me in.
They also say when you go to a country like Russia,
be assured that your phone is probably,
your private phone is probably--
Oh, absolutely, that your phone is taken over.
I actually looked behind the mirrors
of the presidential suite room
where they supposedly had filmed this happening,
and there were electrical wires going into a mirror.
Now, I don't know about you,
but I don't need to turn on my mirror at home.
But these, they had to be turned--
I do have an electric mirror, actually, yeah.
It takes years off my face, yeah.
We were followed everywhere we went.
Were you really?
Yeah, we were followed
by the Russians and we were followed by the Americans.
Like, American intelligence was following us around,
for reasons I can't begin to tell you what, you know,
clown boy here has to be followed for.
You know, you wouldn't mind me making jokes about,
I don't know.
But, no, they actually were very clear
that they were following me.
Like, they would lean out of a crowd and go,
"I work for Trump," and then kinda fade back into the crowd.
(audience laughs)
I'm not joking!
I'm not joking.
I'm sorry, Stephen,
that's the worst espionage I've ever heard of.
(audience laughs)
"Working for Trump, I be!"
What is that?
It's very fitting though!
I didn't say--
Yeah, that's how they speak, yeah.
Yeah, those were whalers too.
Bringing up the old whaling thing again.
Yeah.